besides
that there's no experimental validation
you've written that a big hole
in string theory has been its
perturbative definition
yeah
perhaps that's one can you explain what
that means well maybe to begin with i
mean i think that i mean the simplest
thing to say is
you know the the initial idea really was
that
okay we're we have this
instead of what's great is we have this
thing that only works
that's very structured and has to
work in a certain way for it to make
sense
and um
but but then you ended up you ended up
in ten space time dimensions and so to
get back to physics you had to get rid
of five of the dimension six of
dimensions
and
the bottom line i would say in some
sense it's very simple that what people
just discovered is just
there there's kind of no particularly
nice way of doing this there's an
infinite number of ways of doing it and
you can get whatever you want depending
on how you do it so the you you end up
the whole program of starting at 10
dimensions and getting to four
just kind of collapses out of a lack of
any way to kind of get to where you want
because you can get anything
there'll be the hope around that problem
has always been that
the standard formulation that we have of
string theory which is
you can go in by the name perturbative
but it's kind of um
there's a standard way we know if given
a classical theory of constructing
a quantum theory and
and working with it which is
that's the so-called perturbation theory
that um that we know how to do and that
that by itself just just doesn't doesn't
give you any hint as to what to do about
the six dimensions
so actual perturbed string theory by
itself really only works in ten
dimensions
so
you have to start making some kinds of
assumptions about how i'm going to
go beyond
this formulation that we really
understand of string theory and get rid
of these six six dimensions so kind of
the simplest one was the um
the claudio
postulate
but um
when that didn't really work out people
have tried more and more different
things and and the hope has always been
that
the solution
this problem would be that you would
find a a deeper and better understanding
of what string theory is that would
actually go beyond this perturbative
expansion and would which would um
which would generalize this into and and
that once you had that it would um it
would solve this problem of
it would pick out what to do with the
six dimensions how difficult is this
problem so
if i could restate the problem it seems
like there's a very
consistent physical world operating in
four dimensions
and uh how do you map a consistent
physical world in 10 dimensions to a
consistent physical world in four
dimensions right and how difficult is
this problem is is that something you
can even answer
um
just
in terms of physics intuition in terms
of mathematics
mapping from
10 dimensions to four dimensions well
basically i mean you have to get rid of
the of six of the dimensions so so
there's
i mean there's kind of two ways of doing
it one is what we call compactification
you say that
there really are ten dimensions but for
whatever reason six of them are really
are so so small we can't see them
so you basically start out with 10
dimensions and what we call you know
make make six of them
not go out to infinity but just kind of
a finite extent and then make that size
go down
so small it's unobservable but that's
like that's a math trick
so
can you also help me build any intuition
about
how rich
and interesting the world in those six
dimensions is
so compactification seems to imply
well that's very interesting well no but
the problem is that what you learn if
you start doing math mathematics looking
at geometry and topology and in more and
more dimensions is that
i mean
asking the question like what are all
possible six-dimensional spaces it's
just a it's kind of an unanswerable
question it's just uh i mean it's even
kind of technically undecidable in some
way they're just they're just too too
they're too many things you can do with
all these
if you start trying to make if you start
trying to make one-dimensional spaces
it's like well you got a line you can
make a circle you can make graphs you
can kind of see what you can do but as
you go to higher and higher dimensions
there's just so many ways you can put
things together of and get something
of that dimensionality and
so it it
unless you have some very very strong
principle which is going to pick out
some very specific
ones of these six dimensional spaces
and
they're just too many of them and you
can get anything you want but um so if
you have 10 dimensions
the kind of things that happen
say that's actually the way
that's actually the fabric of our
reality's 10 dimensions there's a
limited set of behaviors of objects i
don't know even know what the right
terminology to use that can
occur when within those dimensions like
in reality yeah
and so like
what i'm getting at is like is there
some consistent constraints
so if you have some constraints that map
to reality
then you can start saying like
dimension number seven is kind of boring
all the excitement happens in the
spatial dimensions one two three yeah
and time is also kind of boring
yeah and like
some are more exciting than others or we
can use our metric of beauty
some dimensions are more beautiful than
others once you have an actual
understanding of what actually happens
in those dimensions in our physical
world as opposed to sort of all the
possible things that could happen in
some sense i mean just the basic factors
you need to get rid of them we don't see
them so you need to somehow explain them
what you have to the main thing you're
trying to do is to explain why we're not
seeing them
and so you you can you have to come up
with some theory of these extra
dimensions and and how they're going to
behave and
string theory gives you some ideas about
how to do that but
but
the bottom line is where you're trying
to go with this whole theory you're
creating is
to just make all of its effects
essentially unobservable so it's a it's
not a really
it's an inherently kind of dubious and
worrisome thing that you're trying to do
there why are you just
adding in all the stuff and then trying
to explain why we don't see it i mean
it's just good this may be a dumb
question but it's is this an obvious
thing to state
that
those six dimensions that are
unobservable or anything beyond four
dimensions is unobservable
or
do you leave a little door open to
saying the current tools of physics and
obviously our brains aren't unable to
observe them
yeah but we may need to come up with
methodologies for observing them so as
opposed to collapsing your mathematical
theory into four dimensions
leaving the door open a little bit too
maybe we need to come up with tools that
actually allow us to directly measure
those dimensions
yes i mean you mean you can certainly
ask you know assume
that we've got
model look look at models with more
dimensions and ask you know what would
be observable effects how would we right
know this and you go out and do
experiments so for instance
you have a
like
gravitationally you have an inverse
square law of forces okay if you had
more dimensions that inverse square law
would change something else so you can
go and start measuring the inverse
square law and say okay an inverse
square law is working but maybe if i get
get and it turns out to be actually kind
of very very hard to measure
gravitational effects and even kind of
you know somewhat macroscopic distances
because they're so small so you can you
can start looking at the inverse square
law and say start trying to measure it
at shorter and shorter distances and see
if there were extra dimensions at those
distance scales you would start to see
the inverse square law fail and um so
people look for that and again you don't
see it but
you can i mean there's all sorts of
experiments of this kind you can you can
imagine which test
for effects of extra dimensions at
different at
different distance scales but
you know none of them
i mean
they all just don't work
nothing yet i think yeah but you could
say ah but it it's if it's just it's
just much much smaller you can say that
which by the way makes ligo and uh the
detection of gravitational waves quite
an incredible project
you